- This video's about me, Nina, okay?
Stop taking all the attention (laughs)
(upbeat music)
(bright music)
Good morning, good morning,
good morning, good morning.
Bit of a rough sleep last night.
My alarm went off at five in the morning
'cause it was still on from the day before
when I had to wake up at
five a.m. to get here.
But it's okay.
Antonio from Real Men, Real Style
invited everyone for breakfast.
So I'm going to go try to find them.
And get started.
Yesterday was just about meeting people.
Today we're actually
going to get some content,
so I'm excited, got some Starbucks.
Ready to go.
And this town has the best bacon
in the world, I just heard that.
- Yeah, Nueske's bacon.
- [Evan] Got to check it out.
(bright music)
Breakfast is still going on.
Lots of good conversations.
This guy's causing trouble, though.
- I'm trying.
- This guy's causing trouble like crazy
(Justin laughs)
Justin.
What's your thing again, science?
It's called Fascinate, SEM
and the science channel.
- Yeah what's your shirt, it's like--
- Science, not silence.
- Look at this one we did, man.
- [Evan] What's that?
- It's Neil the Mass Tyson.
You know, the science communicator--
- [Evan] Oh yeah, okay.
- It's I love asteroids
with the A crossed out.
- (laughs) This guy.
- [Justin] Complete gym
bro, you know, you know.
- This guy, this guy.
So lots of fun.
You know, nobody's filming
inside any of these things,
so again I don't want to be
the guy filming everybody
while they're trying to relax and chill
but lots of really cool
conversations with people.
Got to head to the first session.
Actually going to go back to the room,
drop off some stuff
and head to the first session and see.
One of the things that is a lot of fun
is I'm connecting people together
which is strange for me
'cause I don't really know
that many people here,
but as I have breakfast with somebody,
he could be a good interview
on this other guy's channel.
And it's good, it's working out.
Some fun, I'm excited.
(bright music)
First up, my man Roberto
Blake is doing a session
on designing and branding
your YouTube channel.
He's just getting set up here.
So I'm waiting to do
an interview right now
and one of the things that
I like to do on my breaks
in between sessions when I'm waiting,
these are the guys I'm going
to be interviewing with,
is I go on Instagram, I look at people
who have been viewing my stories recently
and I follow them and
just send them a message.
Just as simple as hey Julie, thank you
for the love on Instagram,
really appreciate it.
I love your bio, some quote
or something in the bio.
And I hope you have an amazing
day and tell you to believe.
That's it, so I've been
sending out, I don't know,
I've sent out probably
a hundred of them or so.
Between today and yesterday.
And we get response.
Let me show you.
Life between two worlds.
Thank you so much Evan.
I am so scared to post
on my personal account
because I don't think my family is going
to be happy when they read it.
I feel you, but you got to decide
whether you're going to live your life
or your family's version of your life.
Make a powerful choice,
today, let's see it, believe.
That's what I do.
That's what I do, let's find another one.
I'll show you.
Supporting the fans.
What's this one?
Hey Evan, wow very surprised
to get a video message.
Thanks a lot bro.
Send him a heart.
Okay, I'll show you.
This is what I do.
This is exactly what I do.
I go to my story.
I'll scroll up.
Okay I just posted that,
nine people have seen it.
I think I've added everybody here.
Let's go back.
Okay.
I'll look at this,
I'll go find someone.
It's Dilip.
Dilip is a programmer with
four posts and 103 followers.
Let's do it.
So I'm going to follow him
and I'm going to make a video.
This is it.
Here we go, I'll show you,
here's what I'm going to do.
Ready?
Hey Dilip, what's up? It's Evan.
Just want to say thanks
for the love on Instagram.
I really appreciate that.
Hope you're having an amazing Wednesday.
I want to see something
special out of you today.
What can you do today to
make it awesome, Dilip?
Let's see it, bring it, bring it.
Believe, man.
That's it.
Rinse and repeat, over and over
and over and over and over again.
The one to one connections.
And it has an impact.
So when you have down time,
that's what I do on my down time.
Hopefully you guys can do something too.
Time for lunch.
(upbeat music)
Lunch with Jessica and Charlie.
- Oh, yeah.
- So I forget where I
left off with you guys.
There's been a couple of great events.
Derral Eves had a good one
on the YouTube algorithm
that was standing room only
and I got there late so I
had to sit on the floor,
just talking with the
Charisma on Command guys.
And then--
- Hey it's Evan Carmichael, BelieveNation.
Hey guys, BelieveNation!
I'm a believer, yes!
How's it going?
- Good, man.
- [Man] Good, good, good.
Subscribe, I mean you probably
already are, I don't know,
alright, see you--
- (laughs) Cheers.
Fun people here.
So the second one I went to was
about getting attention off of YouTube
and using the other platforms
to help you do that.
I'm cooking up my own
strategy around Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter and
maybe stepping that up a bit,
got some ideas I'm going to try to apply
so we'll see how that goes.
Next up, this must be an ice cream social
brought to you by Nintendo.
So I'm going to go try to find that,
get some free ice cream.
I'm ready to eat.
There's no more ice cream.
The ice cream is done.
It's very sad.
Roberto is sad too.
- Yes, I am, yes.
- Roberto told me about the ice cream.
- I wanted the ice cream so much.
- It looked good actually.
I saw people with cones.
It looked good, but...
So, sad.
We'll see what's next.
- Roberto's taking some b-roll
and we decided we're
going to go get some food.
Go get some food, do an interview.
(beeping)
What are these guys riding?
Food, interview.
- [Man] Beeps were for obstacle avoidance.
I might want to get on one of those.
- I think it's for us, us avoidance.
Food, interview, relax.
And then pool party.
Look at how beautiful this park is, eh?
Sittin' on a golf course in Palm Springs.
(bright music)
We managed to hop a ride in a golf cart.
Getting there the fast way.
So that was super fun with Roberto.
Had an awesome meal.
I'm stuffed.
We did an interview for his channel.
That's going to go up
and I'm excited for that.
- Hey everybody, this is Roberto Blake
from robertoblake.com helping
you create something awesome
today with my friend and
special guest Evan Carmichael.
- And the next thing I had
to do was talk to the wife!
That's important.
It's important to talk to the wife.
I was told it's important
to talk to the wife.
Hey, it's Nina.
Everybody misses Nina.
Okay, that's enough air time Nina, okay?
This video's about me, Nina, okay?
Stop taking all the attention (laughs)
We love Nina.
You have to check in with your wife daily
if you're going away.
More than daily, right Nina?
Like every five minutes you have
to check in with your wife (laughs)
Oh wait, they can't hear you
'cause you're in my headphones.
Okay, okay I'm going to
talk to my wife, guys.
Thank you for the love.
(gentle music)
So I had a great chat with Nina.
It was good to see her.
I miss her.
We had some good time to chat there.
Two more days, then I'll be back.
Good day overall.
Losing my voice.
So much talking, chat, chat, chat, chat.
And when I wasn't chatting
I was leaving messages
on Instagram and Twitter and to fans,
so it was really good.
I'm starting to crash.
It is, can you see the time there, 7:17.
Which is 10:17 for me.
The group is out at a trampoline park.
I don't do trampoline parks 'cause I think
I have an inner ear milad or something.
I get dizzy, just like on cruise ships
I get a little nauseous so
I decided I would stay home.
There's another after party
happening at nine or ten
tonight which would be
like 12 or one for me
so I think I'm going to pack
in a little bit early today,
relax, I already have my CNN on.
There's a commercial.
And uh, yeah.
Shower, relax.
And have a great day tomorrow.